frank dvorak teaches this javascript
game development crash course you will
learn how to create a 2d game using
javascript html css and object oriented
programming and frank provides a lot of
free sprites and game art assets so you
can follow along frank is a popular
teacher who creates super creative
courses
what a strange planet it's completely
covered in a thick layer of smoke
initial scans indicate there are no
organic life forms present but i
register a lot of movement coders hope
you like making games let's make a 2d
steampunk game completely from scratch
with html css and javascript no
frameworks and no libraries i will give
you a lot of premium art assets for
characters environments and props and
you can do whatever you want with them
you can use them in your projects and
you can modify them i will show you how
to create gameplay variety by giving
different enemy types different
mechanics that the player can interact
with or has to deal with for example if
you destroy a hive well a bunch of small
drones will come after you let me show
you how to give your games beautiful
visuals and how to apply many special
features i came up with specifically for
this class let's go
these creatures have very similar
physiology to the earth's seahorses body
shape like this can cut easily through
the thick atmosphere of this planet they
can move very fast seahorse hive is
being attacked by something this one has
been damaged i wonder if we can hug this
creature's central computer to control
it for a while it is surprisingly easy
to override its circuits seems like
these machines are not used to our
technology i'm getting a lot of new data
ok explorers we are getting a stream of
data about multiple different species we
will convert their source code into html
css and javascript let's analyze it line
by line and see how it works we have a
lot to learn i will answer all your
questions as we discover more about
their movement special abilities and how
they interact with their planet's
environment let's look under the hood of
this alien ecosystem the atmosphere is
thick enough to allow heavy silicon
based lifeforms to float but smoke is
blocking most of the sunlight many
creatures developed artificial lights
and glowing appendages to see through
the heavy clouds
seahorse sentinel has a basic attack
that's powerful against weak enemies but
if it absorbs energy from one of the
overcharged creatures it gets additional
firepower for a short period of time and
it instantly replenishes its ammo ammo
also automatically recharges over time
it seems we just need to help it to get
through these aggressive swarms in time
so it can join its hive if this is your
first time discovering javascript you
should try some beginner classes first
today's coding will be beginner friendly
but i expect some basic knowledge of
javascript when you get more comfortable
with objects arrays and for loops come
join me in this class
so after a simple basic setup inside
index.html and style css we move into
script.js all javascript logic for this
game will be written here inside this
file i create an event listener for load
event notice that we call it on built in
javascript window object which
represents the browser's window load
event fires when the whole page has been
loaded including all dependent resources
such as style sheets and images we need
to do this because we will use a lot of
graphics in this project and they can
take some time to load if you're trying
to draw an image with the javascript
remember that you always have to wait
for that image to be fully loaded before
you run the javascript code that depends
on that image i usually like to do html
kind of a setup like this custom
variable i call for example canvas will
store the reference to canvas element i
point it towards that element using
getelementbyid
i give it an id of canvas1
now i need so-called drawing context it
is a built-in object that contains all
methods and properties that allow us to
draw and animate colors shapes and other
graphics on html canvas to create it we
need to call a special built-in
getcontext method on a variable that
holds a reference to canvas element so i
say canvas dot get context and then i
need to pass it identifier sometimes we
call this argument a context type we can
pass it 2d or webgl here webgl
represents three-dimensional rendering
context today we will work with 2d
now i access width property on canvas
from line 3 and i set it to 500 pixels
height will be 500 as well
as you can see 500 pixels is wider than
my current browser size for that reason
i also like to declare max with property
and i set it to 100 percent that way the
element will scale down until it's fully
visible in the available browser area i
also declare max height in case the
restricting factor is the height of
browser window doing this will make sure
we can always see the entire canvas
element even when the browser window is
too small i will zoom out a bit to
adjust my workplace for this tutorial
i set canvas width to a larger value and
keep my browser window small canvas
element will scale down to make sure
it's fully visible
to build our game today we will use
object oriented programming which means
we will wrap variables and functions in
objects javascript is a prototype-based
object-oriented language which means it
doesn't have classes it has prototypes
but we can use modern javascript syntax
that introduced classes as so-called
syntactical sugar simplified clean
syntax that mimics classes from other
programming languages still under the
hood it's just working with
prototype-based inheritance one of the
four main principles of object-oriented
programming is encapsulation
encapsulation is the bundling of data
and the methods that act on that data in
objects access to that data can be
restricted from outside the bundle in
this project i will encapsulate our data
into multiple classes each class will
have its special purpose the challenge
for beginners will be to keep track of
how these classes communicate with each
other i will explain everything step by
step as we write the code to help you
understand we need to declare our
classes in a specific order class
declarations are hoisted in javascript
but they stay uninitialized when hosted
that means while javascript will be able
to find the reference for a class name
we create it cannot use the class before
it is defined in the code this means
that i need to declare input handler
class first because i will need to use
it inside player class and so on input
handle class will keep track of
specified user inputs for example arrow
keys
projectile class will handle player
lasers particle class will deal with
falling screws [ __ ] and bolts that come
from damaged enemies
player class will control the main
character it will animate player sprite
sheet and so on enemy class will be the
main blueprint handling many different
enemy types
layer class will handle individual
background layers in our parallax
seamlessly scrolling multi-layered
background and background class will
pull all layer objects together to
animate the entire game world
ui class will draw score timer and other
information that needs to be displayed
for the user
and the main game class will come last
inside this game class all logic will
come together this will be the brain of
our project i hope this gives you a map
of what we need to do to complete our
game let's write javascript logic inside
individual classes and connect them
together i will explain everything step
by step as we go along
[Music]
constructor is a special method on
javascript class when i call this
javascript class later using the new
keyword constructor will create one new
blank javascript object and it will
assign its properties and values based
on the blueprint inside player will need
access to game weight and height and
other properties that will be stored on
the main game object so i will pass it
the main game object as an argument like
this
i convert that game object into class
property on player class like this
i'm saying take this game object that
was passed as an argument to the class
constructor and turn it into class
property called this dot game keep in
mind that by doing this i'm not creating
a copy of the main game object and
placing it on player objects in
javascript are so called reference data
types which means that unlike primitive
data types objects are dynamic in nature
i'm just creating a reference that is
pointing to the place in memory that
stores the main game object so when the
values and properties on the main game
object get updated those changes will be
immediately visible from this dot game
reference inside this player class
i made the size of player sprite sheet
the same size as we will draw them in
game it's a good practice i know that
the width of a single frame in my sprite
sheet is 120 pixels and height is 190.
if you are a beginner it's best if you
use the same sprites and images i'm
using it will make the debugging easier
in case you run into problems you can
always check my code to find the problem
all art assets i'm using are linked
below you can download them from the
project section starting horizontal x
coordinate on the player will be 20
pixels and vertical y position is 100
player will also need an update method
to move it around and draw a method that
will draw graphics representing the
player
for now let's start by increasing
vertical y position on the player by
speed y i need to declare that property
here it will be 0 at first so no
vertical movement
draw method will take context as an
argument this will specify which canvas
element we want to draw on in case our
game has multiple layers with multiple
canvas elements it's also a good
practice to use context argument like
this rather than pulling ctx variable
from the outside directly into our
objects
at first i will just draw a simple black
rectangle representing the player so
built in canvas fill rectangle method
and i want to draw the rectangle at
player's current x and y position and it
will have players with and height
so we have our player object how do we
include it inside game logic and draw it
on canvas as i said the main game class
from line 45 will be the brain of our
entire project all the logic will
somehow go through it again i will give
it a constructor constructor will need
width and height of canvas as arguments
and inside we convert them into class
properties this will make sure
that the width and height of the game
matches the size of canvas element
constructor on javascript class is a
special type of method that will run
once when we instantiate the class using
the new keyword it will create one new
blank object and it will give it values
and properties as defined inside the
blueprint here
i can take an advantage of the fact that
all the code inside the constructor gets
automatically executed like this and any
code i put inside the constructor on
game class will automatically run when i
instantiate my game in a minute so when
i instantiate game class i want it to
automatically create an instance of
player class and i want that instance to
become class property on game class
called this dot player so this.player is
equal to new player like this the new
keyword is a special command in
javascript it will look for class with
this name in this case player and it
will run its constructor method to
create one instance of it based on the
blueprint inside so by calling new
player online 49 javascript will find
player class up here on line 17 and it
will run all the code inside its
constructor i can see that constructor
method on player class needs game as an
argument down here we are inside that
game class so i pass it this keyword
this keyword used inside this class
refers to this entire game object
our game will also need update and draw
methods
update method will take this.player
property from line 49 which holds an
instance of player object and it will
call its update method we defined online
26.
inside draw method we will render the
player on canvas by calling draw method
from line 29. i can see that it expects
context as an argument so i pass it
context like this and that value will be
passed along here
now i create an instance of this new
game class we just wrote and i save it
in a variable i call for example game
it's equal to new game like this again
new keyword will look for class with
that name it will find it on line 45 and
it will run its constructor method to
create one new blank javascript object
and assign it values and properties
based on the blueprint here
on line 46 i can see that game class
constructor expects width and height as
arguments so i pass it canvas width from
line 5 and canvas height from line 6.
so the new keyword triggers a class
constructor as the constructor gets
executed we hit this line which will
automatically create an instance of
player class from line 17.
so this is how by creating the main game
object we also automatically create
player object and now it sits as a
property on the game class on line 49
perfect
[Music]
we will also need animation loop that
will run update and draw methods over
and over 60 times per second updating
positions and redrawing our game i
create a custom function i call for
example animate inside i take the
instance of game class from line 59 and
i call its associated update method we
declared on line 51. i will also call
draw method from line 54 like this i can
see it expects context as an argument to
specify which canvas element we are
drawing on so
i pass it ctx from line 4
this means that this ctx variable will
be passed here and it will get passed
along to draw method on player object
here
now the player knows where we want to
draw it
after we called update and draw we want
to trigger the next animation frame so i
call built in request animation frame
request animation frame method sits on
the window object but we can also call
it just like this
it tells the browser that we wish to
perform an animation and it requests
that the browser calls a specified
function to update an animation before
the next repaint
so we need to pass it one argument and
it will be the method we want to call
before the repaint before browser window
gets updated and redrawn on screen
i pass it animate the name of its parent
function to create an endless animation
loop request animation frame has two
special features it adjusts the user's
screen refresh rate for most of us it
will be 60 frames per second it also
auto generates a timestamp argument and
passes that as an argument to its
callback function a little bit later i
will show you how to use this feature to
create periodic events in our project
events that repeat in a certain interval
i get an error because i misspelled the
word constructor here i'm using vs code
editor it highlights syntax in different
colors which makes it easier to notice
typos like this we have our main game
logic and we are drawing this black
rectangle representing our player
it looks static but it's actually
animating we can test that by giving
players some value here in speed y
property
the reason the rectangle gets longer now
is because we can see old paint we can
see old black rectangles that were drawn
in the previous animation loops i can
fix that by deleting all canvas drawings
between each animation frame between
every animation loop i call built in
clear rectangle method and i want to
clear canvas from coordinates 0 0 to
canvas with canvas height like this now
you can see that because player speed y
property is set to plus 1 the player
moves by 1 pixel per frame in positive
direction on vertical y axis if speed y
is -1 player will move upwards if speed
y is 0 the player will not move at all
it's all because for every animation
frame we are adding speed y property to
player's vertical y coordinate here on
line 27 we know that everything is
working well it's good to test your code
as you go step by step to discover
potential problems i want the player to
be controlled by keyboard when i press
up arrow we set speed y to -1 and player
will move up when i press down arrow we
set speed wire to plus 1 and player will
move down
[Music]
we will handle all player input up here
inside input handler class constructor
will take a game as an argument same as
we did with the player i converted into
this.gameclass property as we said
before when we create an instance of a
class all the code inside class
constructor gets executed we can take
advantage of that and i can even apply
event listeners from here i simply
choose apply event listener like this we
will listen for key down event callback
function on event listener has a special
auto generated argument that contains
all kinds of additional details about
the event that just happened if i want
more details about the keydown event i
just need to pick a variable name and i
pass it as an argument to the callback
usually we use letter e or the word
event but you can also type abc whatever
you put here will become a custom
variable name containing a special
object with additional information about
the keydown event that just happened i
will save it in a variable i call e and
i will console log it if you choose
console.log e you will get the full
event object with many properties i've
done this before so i know i want a
specific property called key so i
console e dot key this will contain a
string with the name of the key that was
pressed let me show you
i need to create an instance of input
handle class so as we did with the
player i want my input class to be
instantiated automatically as i create
my main game class so here inside the
game class constructor i create a
property i call for example this dot
input i set it the new input handler and
i know its constructor expects game as
an argument so same as we did with the
player i pass it this referring to this
entire game class so now as i create
game object down here it automatically
creates player object on line 54 and
input object on line 55. as we call the
new keyword on line 55 javascript will
jump to line 9 and it will run input
handler class constructor which will
among other things apply this key down
event listener that's console login the
current key that is pressed i open
browser console i click on canvas
element so it starts registering events
and now when i press keys on my keyboard
you can see we are console logging the
key property
inside key down event listener i say if
e.k is arrow up
take keys array on the game object
we will create that array in a second
and push that key into the array
i create that array here on line 59
inside game class constructor its job
will be to keep track of all keys that
are currently active that are currently
being pressed down
i will console.log this.game.keys from
here to check if arrow up key is being
correctly added i get a console error
that is saying that the variable name
i'm calling keys from is undefined by
the time this callback function is
executed javascript forgot what
this.game stands for which object it
points towards
we want javascript to remember that this
code initially sits inside this object
so that it can see and remember
this.game property even when we call it
later as we play our game
if you are a beginner don't worry about
fully understanding this yet all you
need to know here is that if javascript
forgets what this keyword stands for we
need to bind that code to the
surrounding codes context
we can use built in javascript bind
method or even simpler we can use es6
arrow function syntax here
a special feature of arrow function is
that this keyword inside arrow function
always represents the object in which
the arrow function is defined arrow
function will never forget that it was
originally defined inside constructor on
input handler class and it will always
see this reference for this.game from
line 10. therefore it will be able to
access this.game.keys and push keys
inside now everything is working when i
press up arrow key it gets added into
this.game.keys
and if i press it multiple times it
keeps adding more and more so i create
another event listener
this time for keyup event
when we release the key i want to remove
it from the array i do that by checking
if the array contains that key so built
in index of array method
the indexof method returns the first
index at which a given element can be
found in the array or it returns -1 if
the element is not present so if
this.game.key's index off is more than
-1 meaning if key's array contains the
key that is currently being released in
this key up event take this.game.keys
array and remove that element from the
array using splice method the splice
method changes the contents of an array
by removing or replacing existing
elements
splice method needs at least two
arguments the first argument is the
index at which we want to start changing
the array so it will be the index of
that key we want to remove like this
and the second argument is delete count
an integer indicating the number of
elements in the array we want to remove
from that starting index
so i call splice i want to remove
elements starting from this index and i
want to remove only one element at that
index
i put the same counter lock inside key
up event you can see that it works well
when i press up arrow it gets added when
i release it it gets removed added
removed nice the problem is when i hold
up arrow key down for too long key down
event will start firing over and over
but key up event doesn't fire so we are
not removing those keys we are adding
multiple keys we are adding the same key
over and over increasing the size of the
array this can also be fixed easily i
only want to add that key into this.keys
array if it's not already present in
there so additional condition here
if this.game.keys
index off the key that was just pressed
is -1
now when i press and hold the key gets
added only once when i release the
button the key gets removed perfect on
keydown event i check if key that was
pressed is arrow up and at the same time
i check if arrow up is not yet in the
array only then i push arrow up into
this dot keys array
on key up event i check if the key that
we are releasing is present in the array
if it is i remove it using splice method
we have the main logic now and adding
more keys is easy just be careful about
brackets here it's easy to miss
something and get an error
i wrap this part in another set of
brackets and i check if key that is
pressed is arrow up or arrow down like
this
now keys array on the main object can
contain nothing and can be empty or it
can contain up arrow key or arrow down
key and it can even contain multiple
keys at the same time in our case both
arrow up and arrow down so now keys
property on the main game object is an
array that always keeps track of presses
and releases of up and down arrow keys
i store this array on the main game
object on line 67 so the information of
what keys are currently pressed is
available all over our code base it's
also available inside our player class
because player has this dot game
property here on line 35 pointing
towards the main game object
i can simply check if this.game.keys
includes a specific key and i can change
player behavior from here i check if
this.game.keys includes arrow up notice
that before i use index of method to
check if element can be found in the
array i can also alternatively use built
in javascript includes method to do the
same thing
the includes method determines whether
an array includes a certain value among
its entries returning true or false as
appropriate
if this line returns true we want player
to move up so we set speed y from line
40 to -1 else if keys array includes
arrow down we set speed y to plus 1.
i save changes and click canvas and now
i can move player up and down by
pressing up and down arrow keys the only
problem is that player will never stop
moving we need to add one more small
condition so else meaning this.game.keys
array doesn't include arrow up or arrow
down we set speed y to zero
instead of hard coding minus one and
plus one here maybe player speed is
dynamic and player can speed up during a
power up for that purpose it's better to
save max speed in a variable like this
so we have current player speed on line
40 and maximum player speed on line 41.
let's try 2 pixels per frame and i
replace hard-coded values with variables
on lines 44 and 45.
if we press arrow up speed y is minus
max speed if we press arrow down speed y
is plus max speed like this now we can
change player movement speed if we need
to by changing max speed value on line
41 and this is one of the techniques i
like to use to handle keyboard inputs in
my games if you have any questions or
any suggestions how to improve this code
let me know by leaving a comment
[Music]
player will be shooting lasers at
enemies we will create them by using a
class i call projectile constructor will
need three arguments the main game
object so that this class has access to
game properties when it needs them and
starting x and y coordinates those need
to be dynamic passed as arguments from
here because starting coordinates of
each projectile will depend on player's
current position as usual i convert the
arguments past to class constructor into
class properties
width will be 10 pixels
height will be 3 pixels
speed will be 3 pixels per frame
update method will also increase
horizontal x coordinate from line 30 by
speed from line 34.
i will also need marked for deletion
property which will be initially set to
false
and if horizontal x coordinate of this
projectile object is more than width of
the game meaning it has moved across the
game area this object can be deleted
i will actually set it to 80 of the game
area so projectiles will be coming from
player here to somewhere around here
because i don't want enemies to be hit
and destroyed off screen let's say that
the lasers have limited range so if
horizontal coordinate of the projectile
is more than 80 of width of the main
game area said they're marked for
deletion property from line 35 to true
this will flag that projectile as ready
to be deleted and removed from the game
we will remove them in a moment before
we do that we will also have a simple
draw method that will take context as an
argument and i call built in fill
rectangle method that will represent the
projectile i want to draw that rectangle
at coordinates this dot x this dot y and
i pass it this dot with this dot height
from lines 32 and 33 we will use images
and animations for everything soon but
first let's set fill style to yellow and
draw yellow rectangles for our lasers
i will also have to define fill style
here on the player a device that yellow
color will apply on it as well
i can set it to green or black like this
so we have our projectile class ready
how do we add them into our game
one way to do it is by creating a
special custom asset on player class
player will have two different attack
modes so i will call the basic one shoot
top in this mode the lasers will be
coming out from the mouth of our
mechanical seahorse when shoot top
method is triggered i take this dot
projectiles array i will create in a
minute and i will push new projectile
inside using the class we just defined
on line 27.
i created this dot projectiles array on
player class this will hold all
currently active projectile objects up
here i can see that class constructor
expects game x and y as arguments so i
pass it this.game from line 51 and the
current player coordinates so this.x
from 954 and dot y from line 55
i want player to shoot when we press a
key so i go up to input handler class
and here i will make it very simple
i go inside key down event and i say
else if key is space bar so just space
like this
you can also use enter or any other key
if you want when we press space bar use
distort game reference from line 10 and
navigate to its player property and from
there call shoot top method we just
defined
since i'm holding all projectiles here
on line 60 on player class i will handle
projectiles here inside update method
i take this dot projectiles array and
for each element in that array i call
update method we defined on line 39
inside that method i have this check
if the projectile moves across the
screen we set its marked for deletion
property to true i want to remove those
elements from projectiles array i will
do it using javascript filter method
like this the filter method creates a
new array with all elements that pass
the test implemented by the provided
function so here i'm taking projectiles
array i call filter on it and the test
is that i want all elements to have
marked for deletion properties set to
false
so exclamation mark here
this will filter out and remove all
elements with marked for deletion
properties set to true and since we just
said that filter creates a new array we
want to override the original array with
the new one that was filtered here
with this line of code in place every
time we set marked for deletion property
to true on any projectile object it will
get removed from projectiles array i
will check if it works by console log in
this dot projectiles from inside shoot
top method i will also call for each on
all projectiles from inside draw method
and i trigger draw method from line 43
on each one i remember that i need to
pass it context so i pass it along the
value from here like this i save changes
and run my code and i can see we have an
error on line 45
i go up to line 45 and i forgot to call
fill rectangle from context so
javascript doesn't know what to do with
it i fix it like this
now i click on canvas and i can move up
and down using keyboard arrow keys and i
can shoot using spacebar in browser
console i can see that projectile
objects are being correctly added and
removed from projectiles array perfect
let's remove these two console logs to
clean up our code
now the console is cleaner and it's
easier to see how projectile array adds
and removes objects nice
right now we can shoot without limits i
want the player to have limited ammo
that slowly recharges over time it will
also get completely refilled when we
collect a special power up fish
down here i say if this.game.amo which
we will create in a minute
is more than zero
only then create new projectile object
i go down here to line 104 and i create
this new ammo property initially we will
start with 20 ammo for example
every time we create a new projectile we
decrease that value by 1.
now i can do it 20 times and then it
stops even if i keep pressing spacebar
we run out of ammo here on line 80 i can
change which coordinates the projectiles
start from in relation to the current
player position
we will match it even better when we
apply player sprite sheet a bit later to
make sure it comes out from the mouth of
our steampunk seahorse we will get back
to this i can offset it here or i can
also do it inside projectile class
itself
[Music]
when we use all 20 projectiles we
completely run out of ammo i want it to
slowly recharge over time to do that i
want to run a periodic event in our code
base and i want to be able to measure
time in milliseconds and say for example
every 500 milliseconds every half second
automatically recharge one ammo to do
that is easy if you know this technique
with timestamps and delta time let me
quickly explain how it works here on
line 116 i create a variable i call for
example last time its job will be to
store a value of timestamp from the
previous animation loop so that we can
compare it against the value of
timestamp from this animation loop
this difference will give us delta time
the difference in milliseconds between
the timestamp from this loop and the
timestamp from the previous loop like
this
where does this timestamp value come
from request animationframe method has a
special feature it automatically passes
a timestamp as an argument to the
function it calls in our case animate i
can use it simply by giving it a
variable name here you can call it
whatever you want as long as you keep
referring to that value using the same
variable name i will call it timestamp
spelled like this and i will use it to
calculate delta time here on line 119
after we used last time to calculate
delta time for this animation loop we
reassign last time to the timestamp from
the current loop so that it can be used
to calculate delta time in the next loop
so request animation frame auto
generates a timestamp value
which is a number in milliseconds since
this loop started we access it here in
animate assign it a variable name for
example timestamp like this we calculate
the delta time which is the difference
in milliseconds between the timestamp
from this animation loop and the
timestamp from the previous animation
loop and then we set last time to
timestamp from this loop so that it can
be used to calculate delta time in the
next loop don't worry if this is a bit
complicated to understand at first it's
a very common technique and it will
become more intuitive as you use it in
multiple projects
i can control delta time to check if
it's working my delta time is around
16.6 milliseconds thousand milliseconds
one second divided by 16.6 is around 60
so i can see that my game is animating
at 60 frames per second let me know if
you get the same value or something else
if you had an old computer delta time
value might be higher because it takes
your computer more milliseconds to
render animation frame if you have high
refresh gaming screen delta time value
could be lower for you i wonder if we
have any coders here who use that type
of screen remember to remove your
console locks when you don't need them
especially this one that runs 60 times
per second it could affect the
performance of our game if i just leave
it here so we calculated delta time we
know how many milliseconds it takes for
a computer to render one animation frame
to run one animation loop i will pass it
to update method here and we can use
that value to run periodic events in our
game or to measure game time the
advantage of this technique is that it
doesn't matter if you have strong super
computer or a very old slow one delta
time measures actual milliseconds in
real time so periodic events will happen
roughly at the same time on slow and
fast machines regardless of their
ability to animate our game slow or fast
to trigger periodic events in our game i
need two helper variables one will be
timer that will go between zero and some
kind of predefined limit each time it
reaches that limit it will trigger some
kind of event and it will reset back to
0 to count again for the next loop
the second helper variable will be that
limit that interval value that timer
needs to reach so i want to replenish
some ammo every half second 500
milliseconds i will also introduce some
hard limit i want the ammo to
automatically replenish only up to this
value not endlessly so starting ammo
will be 20 maximum ammo will be 50 for
example
inside update method on game class i
will use ammo timer and ammo interval
helper variables and also delta time to
trigger this periodic event that
replenishes ammo every 500 milliseconds
i say if ammo timer from line 107 is
more than ammo interval so 500
milliseconds
inside i will also check if ammo is less
than max ammo like this
only then i will increase ammo by 1.
then i reset ammo timer back to 0 so
that it can count again
else keep increasing ammo timer by delta
time
i am calculating delta time on line 128
and i'm passing it to update method on
game class online 131 i make sure update
method expects that value here on line
110 and that delta time value will get
passed along here
our ammo is already recharging but it's
not easy to check and see i can console
these values but it would be nice to
have some visual representation of our
available projectiles as part of our
game screen
i have user interface class here online
95. i will use it to draw messages and
game statuses that player needs to be
aware of
this class will be very simple a
constructor will take a game as an
argument so we convert it to a class
property as usual we will define font
size
and font family we will need it later to
draw some score and game timers
i will also define color and i set it to
white for example
it doesn't need update method it just
needs a draw method
it will expect context as an argument
and here i will draw a small bar for
each available projectile i create for
loop it will run as many times depending
on the amount of ammo we currently have
i will set fill style to this.color
this should actually be outside the for
loop like this
for each available projectile i will
draw a small rectangle
so fill a rectangle method add
coordinates 2050 width 3 pixels and
height 20 pixels
let's draw what we have so far and then
we can finish it once we can see what we
are doing
same as we did with player and input
handler classes i create an instance of
user interface class here on line 116
inside game class constructor
it expects game as an argument so i pass
it this keyword
now i use this dot ui property and i
call its associated draw method we
defined on line 102 and i pass it
context
nice right now we are drawing all 20
available projectiles on top of each
other here to make them align next to
each other i just multiply them by the
index from the for loop like this
20 pixels spacing is too much how about
a spacing of 5 pixels
plus 20 pixels left margin like this
that's better now we can see how our
ammo is slowly recharging
i can change the color here on line 100
i can test it and it's working really
well
it will keep recharging until it reaches
max ammo value of 50 and then it should
stop
yes
we will apply better visuals to our game
in a moment i just want to have a
complete functional game skeleton first
[Music]
we are missing one last important
element in our main game loop enemies
and some enemies will also work as power
ups in this game we will have multiple
enemy types in our game with different
visuals and behaviors let's take it step
by step to make sure we understand how
everything works and how the player
projectiles enemies and power-ups
interact with each other enemy class
will just contain the main blueprint the
properties and methods shared between
all enemy types we will then extend this
class into multiple small subclasses
each enemy type will have a separate
child class that inherits from this main
enemy parent class all enemies will need
access to the main game object so i do
this as usual all enemies will also have
the same starting horizontal
x-coordinate
they will go from right to left starting
just behind the right edge of game area
so this.game.width horizontal speed of
each enemy will be a random number
between -0.5
and -2 pixels because i want them to
move in minus direction to the left on
horizontal x-axis
marked for deletion will be set to false
initially
update method will adjust horizontal x
coordinate by the amount of speed x
value for each animation frame moving
enemies from right to left
i check if enemy moved completely off
screen all the way behind the left edge
of game area so if x coordinate of the
enemy plus its width is less than 0 we
will set its marked for deletion
property to true
draw method will take context as an
argument at first i will just draw red
rectangles representing enemies so fill
style right
and fill rectangle at enemies x and y
coordinates
and its width and height like this
we will have multiple enemy types let's
start with the basic simple anime
angular fish i call that class for
example angular 1 and it extends enemy
class from line 86 in this scenario we
have a parent anime class also called a
super class and we have child angular
class also called a sub class
this is a good example of the second
principle of object oriented programming
called inheritance angler is a child of
parent enemy class and it has access to
its methods such as this update and draw
as well as these properties
if i call a property or a method on
angle class and javascript can't find it
on angular it will automatically travel
to the parent enemy class and it will
look for it there inheritance is used to
reduce code repetition instead of
re-declaring the same methods and
properties on each class i can just
declare them once on parent class and
all child classes will inherit them
automatically
we can also do other things here using a
special super keyword i will show you as
we write the code angle class will have
its own constructor because some
properties will be specific only to
angular fish enemies in our game if i
don't declare constructor on angular
class at all it will automatically use
constructor from anime class from line
87.
in this case i want the code from parent
class constructor online 87 to run and i
want to add some additional properties
here if i just declare constructor on
angular it will completely override
parent class constructor and this code
would be ignored
so i have to use a special syntax to
kind of merge them i want first this
code to run and i want to add a little
bit of it here
i do it by calling super which refers to
super class parent class constructor
this line of code will make sure that
the constructor on the parent gets
executed now i can add some more
properties that will be specific only
for angular remember that if you want to
combine constructors like this you have
to call super first before you use this
keyword doing it the other way around
will give you an error
i have specific sprite sheets ready for
our project so i know that width of a
single frame in our angular sprite sheet
is 228 pixels and height is 169 pixels i
want vertical y position to start from
here and go 90 from the top because we
will have some ground graphics in our
game environment layer these are flying
fish machines they need to be above
ground rectangles and images on canvas
are drawn from the top left corner so i
want the starting vertical position on
each enemy to be between 0 here and 90
of game height here but i need to offset
it by the actual height of the enemy
otherwise they will be drawn too low
down here
that's why i define x coordinate on the
parent enemy class on line 89 but i had
to wait declaring vertical y coordinate
until i had height of that specific
enemy type it will all work together
well now you'll see
inside update method on the main game
class i will cycle through all enemies
and for each enemy object inside enemies
array i will call their update method
i also need to define this.enemies array
here it will hold all currently active
anime objects
i will again use filter method to filter
out all anime objects that have marked
for deletion properties set to true the
same thing we did with projectiles
and i will cycle through all enemy
objects here call their draw method and
pass it context
so we have anime class we are updating
drawing and removing old ones we need to
figure out how to add new enemies into
our game
i will have a special method on the game
class called add anime every time this
method is called it will push one new
anime object inside this dot enemies
array notice that i'm not calling the
parent anime class i'm calling the child
angular 1 class here
on line 103 i can see it expects game as
an argument so
i pass it this keyword because we are
inside that game class
now i want to call add enemy in a
specific interval we will use the same
technique we used to periodically
recharge ammo and it will be much easier
because we are already calculating delta
time
i will need two helper variables enemy
timer that will count between zero and
enemy interval i want to add new enemy
into our game every one second every
thousand milliseconds
same as we did with recharging
projectiles i say if this.enemy timer
which starts from 0 is more than anime
interval
let's go up here and also declare
gameover property and initially set it
to false
back here on 962 i say
and at the same time this dot game over
is false because i don't want to be
adding new enemies when the game ended
and we call at enemy method from here we
will also reset enemy timer back to zero
so that it can count again else meaning
enemy timer is less than enemy interval
we will keep increasing enemy timer by
delta time which is already being passed
to update method here
nice we are adding big red enemies to
our game i go up to 105 and i make the
width and also height smaller just for
now before we start animating sprites i
will make the entire game wider when we
get to later stages for now we are just
building the main logic loop we have
player that can move and shoot
projectiles we have recharging ammo and
there are swarms of enemies coming at us
nice work if you are following along
as usual i want to check if enemies are
being correctly added and removed from
the array so i consoled this.enemies
array here i want to make sure that
filter method on line 161 does its job
and we don't have endlessly growing
array
it works well enemies that moved off
screen to the left are being removed
perfect
it's time to add some interactions i
need to check if enemies collide with
player and also if projectiles collide
with enemies to save ourselves code
repetition i will create a reusable
collision detection method on the main
game object i call for example check
collisions this method will take two
arguments two objects i will call them
rectangle one and rectangle two and it
will return true if they collide and
false if they don't
it will be a reusable function so we can
use it later and pass it player and
enemy as rectangle 1 and 2 and we can
also pass it anime and projectile to
check if they collide let me show you
exactly how to do that right now when
checking if two rectangles collide we
compare their x y width and height in a
specific way so all objects we are
comparing need to have x y width and
height properties for this to work
i will return a statement in brackets
like this so if the code in brackets
evaluates true or false it will
immediately be returned by this function
quick and easy to check if two
rectangles collide we need to run four
checks
we need to check if a horizontal x
position of rectangle one is less than
horizontal position of rectangle two
plus its width if this side is to the
left of this side
i will comment out line 196 just for a
moment so the movement doesn't distract
us
at the same time we need to check if
horizontal position of rectangle 1 plus
the width of rectangle 1 is more than
horizontal position of rectangle 2 if
this side is to the right of this side
if both of these statements are true we
know they're in the same space on
horizontal x-axis but it still doesn't
mean they collide they can be far away
vertically because of that we need two
more checks we need to check if vertical
position of rectangle one is less than
vertical position of rectangle two plus
the height of rectangle two if this side
is above this side and finally we check
if the height of rectangle 1 plus its y
position is more than vertical y
position of rectangle 2 if this side is
below this side
if all 4 of these checks are true this
entire statement will evaluate to true
and check collision function will return
true if at least one of these is false
the entire statement will be false and
we know these two rectangles don't
collide
we stay inside the main game class and
go to its update method in this for each
call we cycle through every object
inside enemiesarray from 941
and we call their update method
as we go through that array one enemy
object at the time we will check
collision between player object from 937
and that particular enemy rectangle
i do this by calling our custom check
collision method we just wrote and i
pass it player as rectangle one and
enemy as rectangle two if this message
returns true we know we are colliding
and i will set marked for deletion on
that animator true i go down to line 200
and i uncomment request animation frame
again so that we can test it
i can see that whenever player collides
with an enemy that enemy gets deleted
perfect we have some interactions in the
same for each method i will also check
each anime against all currently active
projectiles they are stored inside
this.player.projectiles and i call for
each on that array as well like this
for each enemy inside enemies array we
check against every single projectile in
projectiles array
i say if this.check collision between
projectile from this iteration of this
for each
and enemy from this iteration from this
for each
if check collision is true decrease
enemy life by one
at the same time set marked for deletion
on that projectile that collided to true
so it gets deleted
then i check if enemy lives are less or
equal to zero
and if they are set marked for deletion
on that enemy to true as well
and lastly i will increase score by plus
one
actually i want each enemy to give
different amount of score points when
defeated so we will increase game score
by score property on that enemy
now i used three properties that don't
exist yet i go up to parent enemy class
and i declare them here i set lives to 5
and score that this enemy rewards will
be equal to the number of its lives like
this
i will also draw that number on top of
each anime for debugging purposes by
calling fill text here i pass it distort
lives from line 92 and x and y
coordinates of that enemy it's very
small so i will set fill style to black
and font property will be set to 20
pixels helvetica for now
[Music]
i need to define score on the main game
class here on line 154
and i will also define winning score
let's set it to 10 points for now so
it's easy to test
every time we increase score here we
check if the current score is more than
winning score and if it is game over
from line 153 is true
i go up to line 130 inside draw method
on ui class in this area i will write
code to display the current score to the
user i call build in fill text method
again and i pass it the text i want to
draw so this.game.score
and i want to draw it at coordinates
2040. i set font property to this.font
size from line 126 plus pixels space
plus this.font family from line 127.
i put a string that says score colon
space here plus we will concatenate
this.game.score
let's see if everything works
all seems to be fine except for the text
colors jumping around i will move this
fill style declaration up here and i set
this dot color to white
i can also do other adjustments to the
text for example shadows if i want the
shadows to apply only to the text and
not all the shapes on canvas i will put
it between built in save and restore
canvas methods
save method of canvas 2d api saves the
entire state of canvas at that point in
time that includes settings like stroke
style fill style line width global alpha
all shadow settings we will use in a
minute as well as other things like
clipping region or the current
transformation matrix so whatever we do
with scale translate and rotate canvas
methods then we can change the state of
canvas however we want and we call
restore canvas restore method restores
the most recently saved canvas state if
there is no saved state this method does
nothing so save and restore only work
when used together i will start applying
canvas shadows if i did that outside
save and restore shadows would get
applied to everything including player
and enemies but in our case these
shadows will only affect shapes and text
we draw in this area between this save
and this restore shadow offset x defines
the distance that shadow will be offset
horizontally it can be positive or
negative depending on if you want the
shadow to be to the left or to the right
from the source element shadow offset y
defines vertical distance of the shadow
i set shadow color to black i could also
set shadow blur but i don't need it at
this time so by wrapping code in save
and restore i make sure that canvas
shadows and this fill style property
affect only this drawing code and not
other shapes and graphics we are drawing
on the same canvas element this is a
pretty solid code base you can use this
as a base boilerplate for many different
games maybe some of you want to make a
copy of this project at this state and
save it in a different folder so you can
experiment with it later and use it as a
starting point of a different game
project
[Music]
win and lose condition in our game will
depend on how many score points can the
player get in a specific time window we
are going to handle those game over
messages here before we call restore
so if game over property on the main
game object is true we set text align to
center
we are going to display message 1 in
larger letters and under that there will
be message 2 and smaller font what these
two messages say will depend on how many
score points we managed to get in a
specified game time
i check if game score is more than
winning score
message 1 will say
you win
and message two will say well done
so that's our winning message else we
display the losing message so message
one is you lost
message two is try again next time
[Music]
now we actually need to draw these
messages on canvas so font for the first
message will be 50 pixels space plus
font family
then i call fill text and we draw
message 1 in the center of the screen
so x coordinate will be game with times
0.5 vertical y coordinate will be game
height times 0.5
i copy these two lines of code and i
change some things to draw message to in
smaller letters 25 pixels here and
message 2 here
i try to play the game and win
nice we get a winning message i need to
create some space between the lines so
first message will be minus 40 pixels
vertically and the second message plus
40 pixels vertically
let's see
yeah this is fine for now
[Music]
we need a time limit for our game on the
main game object i create two helper
variables i call them for example game
time which will start at 0 milliseconds
and time limit for testing purposes time
limit will be 5000 milliseconds 5
seconds after 5 seconds the game will
end and depending on how many score
points we managed to get we will display
winning or losing message
in update method i say if game over is
false take game time from line 181 and
increase it by delta time delta time is
the difference in milliseconds between
timestamp from this animation loop and
the timestamp from the previous loop so
it's the amount of milliseconds between
frames by adding delta time to game time
every time we draw a new frame we are
keeping track of how many milliseconds
passed since the game started game time
variable is simply just accumulating
milliseconds since the game started
if game time is more than time limit
from line 182
so when the game has been running for
5000 milliseconds we set game over to
true the final game will run longer i
just use 5 seconds time limit here so
it's easy to test
up inside ui class we want to draw game
timer on screen let's do it in this area
on line 143
i call fill text and the text will say
timer colon plus this dot game.time
add coordinates 20 100.
actually the variable we just created
was called game time like this and i
need to add space here
nice
so we can see game timer i want to
format that value so it looks a bit
cleaner i create a temporary helper
variable called formatted time
i want to move the decimal point to show
seconds so
this.game.gametime times 0.001
that works i also want to display only
one digit after the decimal point so i
use built in two fixed method and i pass
it one two fixed method formats a number
using fixed point notation we can use it
to define the number of digits we want
to appear after the decimal point
perfect we have game time functionality
i'm getting a buck when i get a losing
message and then i defeat a couple of
remaining enemies and that message
switches to the winning message i want
to make sure that after game over
message appears we are no longer able to
gain more score points down here inside
update method on game class i only want
to increase score if game over is false
i get an error it's supposed to be
this.gameover like this
this will fix the bug
we have the base game we have player
enemies and projectiles we have
recharging ammo score timer and win and
lose condition you can save this code in
a separate folder and use it as a base
skeleton for many different games if you
want from this point i will start adding
graphics and features that will be
specific to our steampunk alien game
this will be the fun part let's go
[Music]
we will be using large detailed images
and graphics today i will put all of
them here inside index html and because
all the code in script.js is inside
event listener for load event javascript
will only run after all our images have
been fully loaded this will prevent
errors
i will separate art assets in this
project into three different categories
characters which will include player and
enemies props which will include things
like mechanical parts that fall from
enemies when we damage them and game
environment
let's start by creating the game world
first img element with an id of layer 1
and source will point towards that png
file you can download all project images
in the description i will put all my
images into a project folder i call
assets our game world will be made out
of four separate layers for parallax
scrolling effect layer one two three and
four like this
i don't really want to draw these images
on the web page like this i only want to
draw them on canvas with the javascript
so inside style css i set all of them to
display none
in script js on line 116 we have a
custom class i called layer its job will
be to set up each individual layer
object constructor will expect three
arguments coming from the outside game
image and speed modifier
i convert those arguments into class
properties like this
the width of the images we are using is
1768 pixels and the height is 500 pixels
horizontal x coordinate will start at
zero
and y will also be zero
we will need update method to move the
background layers from right to left as
the game scrolls if horizontal x
coordinate is less or equal to minus
width from line 121 meaning the
background image has moved across the
screen and is now fully hidden behind
the left edge of canvas we set x back to
zero so that it can scroll again
else decrease x by game speed times
speed modifier each layer object will
have different speed modifier to create
parallax but all will depend on the main
game speed variable so that all four
layers can be controlled from one place
gamespeed variable doesn't exist yet so
i created on the main game class here
initially i set it to 1.
layer class will also need a draw method
it will take context as an argument i
call built in draw image method this
method needs at least three arguments
image we want to draw so this dot image
from line 119 and where on canvas we
want to draw it so i want to draw it at
this dot x this dot y from lines 123 and
124 so we have our layer class which
will handle individual background layers
we will also need background class that
will put all four layer objects together
to create the game world constructor
will take the main game object as an
argument i convert it into a class
property like this
here we will grab all four images for
each layer with javascript so
this.image1 will be
by document.getelementbyid and i pass it
layer one the id i gave it in index html
this.layer1 property will be an object
that holds an instance of layer class
from line 116 so new layer like this
on line 117 i can see that layer class
constructor expects game image and speed
modifier arguments so i pass it this dot
game from line 137
this look image 1 from 938 and speed
modifier will be one for now
update method will move all the layer
objects
and draw method will draw all of them
we will hold all layer objects inside
this dot layer's property it will be an
array let's start with just layer one
inside update method i take these dot
layers and i call for each
method for each layer object call their
associated update method we declared on
line 126
draw method will expect context as an
argument to specify which canvas we want
to draw on
inside we will do the same thing call
for each on layers array and for each
layer object trigger its draw method and
pass it that context value because we
know that the draw method on line 130
expects that argument
so background will handle all layers to
create the game world layer class will
handle logic for each individual
background layer object separately
now to animate the background i just
need to create an instance of background
class inside game class constructor same
as we did before with player and input
handler classes background class expects
game as an argument so i pass it this
keyword because i am inside that game
class right now
inside blade method on game class i take
this new background property and i call
its update method
inside the draw method on game class i
call draw method on the background
object and i pass it context along here
notice that i am drawing background
first then the player this will make
sure that the background is behind the
player and doesn't cover it
i'm getting an error
i go back to my background class and i
want to put this layer 1 object into the
array so i have to use this keyword
nice we are animating layer 1 of our
background
i can change scrolling speed by changing
the value i pass as a speed modifier if
i pass it 5 the game speed is 1 because
i'm multiplying game speed times speed
modifier 1 times 5 is 5 so background
will scroll at the speed of 5 pixels per
frame
i will bring all other layers into the
project
i bring their images first then for each
one i create an instance of layer class
and i put all of them inside this dot
layers array
okay now we see all four layers
i give each layer a different speed
modifier
these values are passed as speed
modifier and they will be multiplied by
the current game speed you can control
scrolling speed of each layer
individually like this
for now i will set speed modifier to 1
on all 4 layers
you can see that because of line 128 as
soon as the layer images slide
completely off screen they reset back to
x position of 0 so that they can slide
again we are getting this gap to get a
seamless scrolling background effect we
can use a simple trick we can place a
second identical image next to the first
one so at the point where the first
image doesn't fill the entire game area
the second image comes in to fill the
gap the second image will never be fully
visible it will be filling in just for
that short period of time before the
first image can reset to its starting
position again reset to the original
position happens in one frame so it's
not visible by naked eye it will create
an illusion that we have one endless
seamless background how do i apply that
in code i simply draw a second identical
image but i need to make sure it is next
to the first one the second image will
start where the first image ends so its
horizontal x position will be this dot x
plus this dot width like this
and that's it we have endless parallax
background implemented in our game
i can change its scrolling speed by
adjusting speed property on the main
game object or i can change speed
modifier values i pass as arguments when
i create individual layer objects
i'm getting a small stutter when the
background image is reset back to
position 0. i fix that by removing this
else statement here
now the reset should be smooth and not
noticeable
i can also use small values as speed
modifiers
i want the back layer to scroll very
slowly if i use speed modifier 0.2 and
base game speed is 1 that layer will
scroll by 0.2 pixels per frame because
we are multiplying game speed by speed
modifier
i will try 0.2
0.4
1 because layer 3 is this ground image
so that it should scroll the same speed
as the rest of the main game objects and
layer 4 are these items in the
foreground so i will make them scroll at
1.5 base game speed
the issue we have right now is that
layer 4 these foreground objects should
be in front of the player but right now
they are behind because in the main
animation loop i'm drawing all four
background layers before i draw the
player there are multiple ways to solve
this i'll use the simplest possible
solution
i will draw only layer 1 2 and 3 here as
part of the background class and remove
layer 4 to draw it separately later
because i removed layer 4 from the array
i need to call its update method first
from inside update method on the main
game class here on line 226 i'm calling
background.update which updates layers 1
2 and 3 and i will also call update on
layer 4 like this
inside draw method we are redrawing all
elements that make up our game for every
animation frame first we draw the
background which now contains only layer
1 2 and 3. then we draw the player on
top of that then we draw ui then enemies
and on top of everything we will draw
background layer 4 to make it appear in
front of all other game objects
the thing to understand is that since we
are drawing everything on the same
canvas element what is drawn first will
be drawn behind the thing that is drawn
after
background will be behind the player
time to draw the player we start by
bringing player image into the project
here in index html i created this
seahorse sprite sheet that you can
download and use we will have basic
swimming animation and we will have
power up animation row because when the
player collects a special overcharged
fish it will absorb its energy the
player's eyes and chest will light up
and player will shoot two lasers instead
of one in script.js i go to line 59
inside player class constructor and i
bring the image into the project using
getelementbyid same as we did with
background images
in style css i give player image display
none
we are bringing the image into
javascript project here on line 59.
inside the draw method currently we are
drawing a black rectangle representing
the player to draw the sprite sheet i
will use built in canvas draw image
method
i pass it the image i want to draw so
this dot image from line 59 and x and y
coordinates where i want to draw it i
want to draw it at player's current x
and y position from lines 54 and 55. you
can see we are drawing the entire sprite
sheet with all its frames and rows draw
image method can accept three arguments
like this we can also give it five
arguments by adding width and height
in case of a sprite sheet like this it
will just squeeze all frames into an
area of one frame we don't really want
that
what we need is the longest version of
draw image method that expects nine
arguments and it gives us the most
control over the image we want to draw
on canvas those nine arguments are image
we want to draw source x source y source
width and source height of the area we
want to crop out from the source image
and destination x destination y
destination with and destination height
to specify where we want to draw that
cropped out piece of image on
destination canvas we will need some
helper variables as well frame x will
cycle through the sprite sheet
horizontally frame y will determine row
of the sprite sheet in this case row 0
or row 1.
i need to crop out just one frame from
the source sprite sheet image so source
x will be frame x times width of a
single frame which in our case is the
width of player because i like to size
my images to the same size we will draw
them in game
when frame x is 0 we display this frame
when frame x is 1 1 times width of 120
pixels is 120 so we will draw this frame
frame x 2 will be 2 x 120 so 240 pixels
this frame and so on it will work the
same with frame y vertically frame y
times height of the player which is
identical to the height of the sprite
sheet frame source width is width of a
single frame
source height is height of a single
frame
now we are cropping out just one frame
perfect
[Music]
i will animate the sprite sheet by
cycling between frames horizontally from
0 to max frame in the case of player
sprite sheet max frame is 37 we count
from 0.
i will handle sprite animation logic
down here it's simple if frame x from
line 56 is less than max frame from line
58 increase frame x by 1.
else reset frame x back to zero
if you prepare your sprite sheets well
in graphics editor the way i prepared
the sea horse for you you only need very
little code to get the animation
if i set frame y to 1 we will see the
second row in the sprite sheet we will
use that for power up state for now i
set it back to 0.
[Music]
at this point i no longer need the black
rectangle that represents the player but
it is still useful to keep track of that
area because it will be player's hitbox
used for collision detection i replace
fill rectangle with stroke rectangle i
remove this fill style declaration
stroke style will be black by default
unless we set it to a different color
i want to have a debug mode in my game
when i press letter d the game will show
hitboxes and maybe other things like
enemy hit points player hitbox is this
black rectangle we are outlining so i
only want to draw that if game.debug is
true
i need to create that property so down
here inside game class constructor i say
this.debug is true
the last thing i need is to create a
switch that will allow the user to
toggle debug mode on and off by pressing
letter d
to create a toggle with javascript is
simple i go up inside our input handler
class and inside key down event listener
i create an else if statement and i
check if the key that was pressed is
letter d
if it is i set the new debug property we
just created on the game object to its
opposite value so if it's true i set it
to false if it's false i set it to true
now when i play my game i can toggle
debug mode on and off by pressing the
letter d at this point debug mode only
shows and hides player hitbox but we
will attach more functionality to it a
bit later
nice we are making a lot of progress
let's add more characters to the game
the base game loop will have three enemy
types i created multiple animations for
each enemy type to give our game more
variety and i will show you how easy it
is to swap between them you can download
all our datasets in the project files in
the section below i made these
characters spreadsheets for you so feel
free to keep them for your personal
projects you can modify them and do
whatever you want with them you can
credit me if you use it for your
personal projects but only if you want
also if you want the base photoshop
files or separate pieces in png format
for all these characters so that you can
animate them and turn them into
spreadsheets yourself let me know the
best free software to create custom
sprite animations is dragonbones if you
want more advanced features there is
also a paid software called spine you
don't need any of that because i'm
already giving you complete ready to use
sprite sheets this is just for those of
you who want to learn more and create
custom animations or different
animations than the ones i created for
you so i'm bringing three new images
into the project
angular 1 will be the most basic
anglerfish anime type the sprite sheet
has multiple different animations for
the same character model and we will use
all of them in a minute
the second character is a different type
of angler fish with more gears and
chimney
these are steampunk machines that come
to life i gave them a lot of mechanical
parts these two anglerfish enemies will
be just a simple basic enemy type that
comes at the player trying to eat it
they are not very resistant and they are
easy to deal with using our seahorse
sentinel lasers the only advantage they
have is that they can come in big
numbers sometimes to deal with that we
have to be smart and use our slowly
recharging ammo wisely we can use the
third enemy type to help us i call this
third enemy type luckyface because it
will be an enemy but also a power up at
the same time it will have two different
models different skins that we will use
randomly when we create a new one and
the way we use this enemy type to make
gameplay more interesting is that the
player can do two things when this enemy
appears we can shoot it for a lot of
score points or we can collide with it
to collect it as a power up it doesn't
have many life so players also have to
be careful not to destroy it
accidentally before they can collect it
and activate the power up the story is
that this is an overcharged fish and
when the sentinel sea horse collides
with it it absorbs its light and power
to activate its ultimate offensive mode
for a short period of time it will all
be represented by graphics to make it
clear to the user what's happening so
here is the parent anime class and here
we have a child angle 1 class that
extends it and inherits from it
i will add this.image property and i
point it towards the sprite sheet we
just included in index.html like this
we have three different animations that
loop and when we create a new angular
fish we will assign it one of these
three randomly by setting this dot frame
y property to a random number between
zero or one or two so mass at random
times three
wrapped in math floor
like this
right now we have these small red
rectangles representing each anglerfish
enemy same as i did with player i
replace fill rectangle with stroke
rectangle and i remove this fill style
declaration
and also this one
the draw enemy sprite sheet same as we
did with player sprite sheet i use
built-in canvas draw image method i pass
it image i want to draw so this dot
image from line 124
if i just pass it x and y coordinates it
will draw the entire big sprite sheet
with all frames and all rows i declare
frame x that will help us to navigate in
the spreadsheet horizontally
frame y will navigate vertically
[Music]
max frame will be the maximum horizontal
frame which is 37 for this particular
sprite sheet
i only want to draw enemy hitboxes when
debug mode is active so this line will
run only if this.game.debug is true
i want to draw them at the original full
size so i remove this temporary size
modifier we created earlier
if i pass a draw image method additional
width and height we will squeeze all
frames into an area of one frame
so i will add four more to define an
area i want to crop out same as we did
with the player so source x source y
source with and source height
so image i want to draw four arguments
for the area i want to crop out from the
source image and four arguments for
where to place that cropped out image on
destination canvas
source x will handle horizontal cycling
through the sprite sheet and it will be
frame x from line 106 times width from
line 124. we keep width property on a
subclass because it will be different
for each enemy type
source y will be frame y from 107
times height from line 125.
source width will be this.wave
source height is this.height
i'm giving you sprite sheets that are
already sized exactly as they will be
drawn in the game so we don't have to do
any scaling with code here it's simpler
and it's more performance efficient to
do it this way
the sprite animation itself will be
simply going between frame x0 and max
frame over and over
we will handle it here inside update
method if frame x from 106 is less than
max frame from line 108 increase frame x
by one else reset frame x back to zero
and we are animating our first enemy
type the final game will be wider i just
keep the game area smaller so that i can
show you everything on one screen
in style css i hide images with id angle
1 angle 2
and lucky
[Music]
i can set the game width to 700 pixels
so that the large enemies fit better
you can see that each enemy fish has
been randomly assigned one of the three
possible animations i prepared for you
it gives our game a nice variety
a needs to account for game scrolling
speed when calculating anime positions
so down here inside update method on
enemy class i say this dot x plus equals
this dot speed x minus
this.game.speed
this way we can have dynamic events that
change game speed and enemies will
always be correctly positioned in
relation to our scrolling game world
[Music]
let's add the second type of angularfish
i created for you i copy this child
class that extends the parent enemy
class and i call it angular 2.
width of a single frame is 213 pixels
and height is 165 pixels
for this anime model i created two
different animations so frame y can be
row 0 or row 1.
so now we have two different anime types
i want to have a simple functionality
where i say something like when you
create a new enemy in the game in 50 of
cases make that enemy angular 1
otherwise make it angular 2. we will
handle that logic inside add nme method
we will do it by rolling dice once every
time we create a new enemy so helper
variable i call randomize
is math.random math at random declared
like this will generate a random number
between 0 and 1. if that random number
is less than 0.5 create angular 1 enemy
type
else create angular 2.
up here on line 249 i increase game
limit to 15 seconds so we have some more
time to test everything before game over
is triggered immediately i can see the
new angular 2 enemy type
and i can see we are playing both
animations perfect
giving graphics like this for your game
will go a long way to help you create
unique stories and adventures for your
players if you are interested how to
take drawings of static characters and
turn them into animated sprite sheets
with free dragon bone software like i
did with this seahorse and angular for
this class let me know and i might make
a course on that
on enemy class i have this dot lives and
this dot score properties i want each
enemy to have different values here so i
cut it here and i paste it on each enemy
type individually
angular 1 will have 2 lives and when we
defeat it we will get 2 score points
angle 2 will have 3 lives and it will
give 3 score points quick test to see if
everything works i can see enemy lives
and it gives the correct amount of score
points
don't worry about the color of the
numbers right now we will fix that later
[Music]
let's create a third enemy type i copy
this code block and i will call this
subclass luckyfish for example
width will be 99 pixels and height 95.
this fish will have three lives and if
destroyed it will award 15 score points
i will give it a property i call type
and i will set it to lucky we will use
this to check which enemy type player
collided with
down on line 314 inside add anime method
i add another else if statement like
this
if random number is less than 0.3 we
create angular 1 else if it's less than
0.6 we create angular 2. when the random
value is between 0.6 and 1 we create
luckyfish using the new class we just
wrote
there's something strange happening with
the animation i go up to luckyfish class
to see what's wrong
i can see that on line 153 i need to
point
this dot image property to the correct
sprite sheet
and we are animating our special
luckyfish powerup
there are two models because the sprite
sheet has two rows and we are
randomizing vertical coordinate with
frame y here on line 154
[Music]
when the player collides with one of
these special overcharged fish it enters
a powerup mode let's write that code now
we start by declaring this.powerup
property on the player up here on line
65. initially i set it to false powerup
will last for a while and then the
player will go back to the normal state
so we will need another timer
we can use delta time for it
we will have two helper variables called
powerup timer and powerup limit powerup
timer will be count in milliseconds
when it reaches power up limit of 10 000
milliseconds 10 seconds powerup state
will end
we will handle that logic here in update
method on player class i say if this dot
power up from line 65 is true we enter
this code block
inside we check if powerup timer is more
than powerup limit
and if it is we set powerup timer back
to 0
and power up to false
we will also set player sprite sheet to
frame y 0 so normal default animation
else meaning power up is true and power
up timer is not yet higher than power up
limit the player is in power up mode and
powerup timer is counted in milliseconds
by adding delta time we calculated delta
time before inside the main animation
loop is the difference in milliseconds
between timestamp from previous and the
current loop we need to make sure update
method expects delta time as an argument
on line 69
and we pass it to this method inside
update method on the main game class
here on line 286
so we are counting timer and frame y is
on the second row so value is one we
come from zero that will give us a
special animation with light coming from
chest and eyes and also tail will
animate differently because while in
this state we will shoot two lasers one
from the nose and one from the tail at
the same time two lasers for the price
of one ammo
at the same time we will be recharging
ammo by 0.1 per frame and this will be
on top of the regular recharging speed
so ammo will be recharging very fast
while in power up mode so when powerup
is set to true we enter this code block
powerup timer is increasing by delta
time counting how many milliseconds we
are in powerup mode frame y is animating
special overcharged animation and ammo
is recharging fast
as soon as power up timer increases over
the value in power up limit which will
happen after 10 seconds 10 000
milliseconds we set power up timer back
to 0 we set power up to false and we set
animation rule back to normal regular
floating animation
inside update method on game class
in this area where we check for
collision between player and enemies we
check if type property on that enemy is
set to lucky
if it is we call a special method on the
player object called enter powerup we
will write it in a minute
else if we collided with another anime
that is not luckyfish we decrease score
by 1 as a penalty to the player this
will encourage player to collide with
power up fish and avoid regular enemies
to get maximum possible score
i go up to player class here on line 111
i create that method so enter power up
its job will be to set everything up
when player enters power up state
i could have used state design pattern
but we don't have that many player
states so we can do it simply like this
when we enter power up we set power
powerup timer back to zero in case we
collided with powerupfish while we are
already in powerup state this will make
sure the time resets and we get full 10
seconds from that second collision
we set powerup property on player object
to true we will also recharge the ammo
to its maximum possible value
i test it
i collide with our special overcharged
fish and player gets overcharged we are
in powerup mode and ammo is instantly
refilled and it's recharging very fast
perfect after 10 seconds power up ends
ammo stops recharging because we are
well over max ammo value and player
sprite sheet switched to the basic
floating animation
great
so when we are in powerup mode our
sentinel seahorse will shoot defensive
lasers from mouth and tail at the same
time
it's overflowing with energy and it can
shoot extra free projectiles from tail
every time it shoots one from the mouth
we can handle that functionality with
javascript very easily by declaring
additional method i call should bottom
in shoot top we handle shooting from the
mouth and shoot bottom we will handle
logic for tail lasers
so inside i check if ammo is more than
zero and we just push new projectile
into projectiles array
i adjust its horizontal and vertical
starting position because i want it to
be coming out from the tail
i will call this method from inside
shoot top like this while we are running
the code in shoot top we check if we are
in power up mode
and if we are we execute shoot bottom
method as well to add that extra free
projectile
i tested lasers are just coming out from
sears's mouth in basic floating state
if we collect the power up fish we enter
power up mode and both should stop and
shoot bottom methods are running we are
shooting two projectiles but it costs
only one ammo
getting overcharged makes the player
very powerful maybe we need some bigger
bulkier enemies so we get more challenge
i made two types of mechanical whales
for player to defeat probably you will
need these power apps to do so
[Music]
i want the projectiles to come from
behind the player we are drawing
projectiles inside a draw method on
player class if i want them to be drawn
behind i need to make sure we draw
projectiles first and the player second
like this
i want to make it even more visually
clear when powerup mode is active for
example i can make this ammo display up
here different color while in powerup we
draw all these ui elements in our custom
ui class
on line 243 before i draw all these
small rectangles representing ammo i
check if power up property on player
class is true if it is i set fill style
to a different color i want that color
to be similar to the glow effect we have
on our sprite sheets so maybe this
it works the problem is that it also
recolors the timer text because we
define fill style here we draw ammo and
then we draw the timer
i can keep drawing ammo at the same
coordinates in our game and i can move
this entire code block further down
[Music]
that way this white fill style will
apply to timer and the other color will
apply only to ammo like this
[Music]
instead of drawing a rectangle
representing a laser projectile we can
also use an image i bring it into the
project here in props section in index
html you can download it in the video
description or you can use your own
image i give it an id of projectile
i bring it into the project here on line
38 inside projectile class constructor
this dot image equals to
document.getelementbyid and i use the id
i just gave it so right now we are
drawing yellow rectangles representing
our projectiles i delete that and
instead i will use draw image method
this time it's simple because the image
is already the right size
i just give it three arguments the image
i want to draw and x and y coordinates
where to draw it on canvas
nice we are drawing images these
projectiles can also be animated either
using a special sprite sheet or all
different kinds of particle effects we
will use sprite sheet to animate
projectiles in a bonus section of this
course
[Music]
let's add a web font to make the text
look better
adding a font to a canvas game is very
simple i go to google phones and i
search for bangers i like this comic
book style
when you have your font you click select
your style here you can select multiple
different fonts like this if you want
then we go up here to view selected
families if you choose more than one
this code will be adjusted to contain
all of them as part of a single
declaration all we need to do to bring
the font to our project is to copy these
link tags and paste them up here in
index html ideally above the main css
style sheet to make sure the fonts are
available from there as the code gets
executed line by line from top to bottom
i go back to google phone's website and
here it also gives us a ready-made css
font family declaration i copy it and i
put it inside our style css file here on
canvas element
now my font is available so i go to
script js inside ui class i set this
custom font family property we wrote
before to bangers and now all the texts
drawn by ui class so score timer and
game over messages will use the new font
let's adjust the winning text to
something less boring i want to keep the
victorian steampunk explorer theme going
for this game so winning message will
say most wonders in big letters
and with an exclamation mark
secondary smaller message will say well
done explorer
for the losing message let's use another
old phrase i will say blazes with an
exclamation mark it's a word for when
something goes wrong in old english
secondary small message will say
get my repair kit and try again for
example
you can come up with your own messages
here if you want now i have my messages
in a new font so i can adjust the sizing
and spacing
i want the main message one to be much
bigger i try 150 pixels
well that's way too big we could also
adjust the text size to match the width
of canvas but let's keep it simple for
now and set it to 100 pixels
hm i think i will go with 70 pixels
i want the messages to be closer
together so instead of 40 pixels offset
i tried 20 for both of them
i'm happy with the spacing and font size
for now
i can see that we still have the
projectile image visible in the top left
corner of the browser window so install
css i set it to display none
we can also see the spacing of the
losing message now looks good
i would also like the little numbers
above each enemy that represent their
lives to be only visible when debug mode
is active to do that i go up to enemy
class and inside draw method i only want
to call that fill text method if debug
mode is active if debug property on the
main game object is true
let's test it
yes i can only see hitboxes and enemy
lives when in debug mode perfect
i want to make sure that player cannot
leave the screen right now if you press
up or down arrow for long enough player
will move completely off screen inside
update method on player class we will
handle vertical boundaries
let's start with the bottom boundary if
this dot y vertical position of the
player is more than the height of the
game minus the height of the player
meaning that the bottom edge of the
player is touching the bottom edge of
the game area make sure we cannot move
past this point
like this
i actually want the player to disappear
halfway so that it can avoid very big
dangerous enemies we will add soon i
will do that by multiplying player
height times 0.5 here and here now we
can move half the sea horse's body
outside the screen and then we hit the
boundary we just defined
i will do the same thing for the top
boundary else if player's current
vertical y coordinate is less than minus
player height times 0.5 meaning that the
top half of the seahorse is off screen
make sure it cannot move any further up
like this i test it
top boundary works
bottom boundary works perfect
[Music]
up on line 48 we have a particle class i
will use it to create broken parts
falling from enemies every time we hit
them and for a big spray of spare parts
when we completely destroy an enemy we
will also make those parts bounce from
the floor for a specific number of times
before they fall off screen particle
class constructor will need a reference
to the main game object start in
horizontal x coordinate and start in
vertical y coordinate i convert those
arguments into class properties as usual
we will use a sprite sheet with nine
images in a grid each particle object
will randomly choose one of these images
so that we have some variety
this dot image is documented to the
getelementbyid
and id will be gears
in index.html i bring it into the
project here in the props section id is
gears and file name is gears.png you can
download it in the project section as
usual
install css i hide it by giving it
display none
here we are referencing that image with
javascript i will need some helper
variables to navigate around the sprite
sheet each particle object each spare
part flying from the enemy will have a
random image assigned from these nine
available options frame x will be a
random number between 0 and 2 so column
0 or 1 or 2.
frame y will be the same so row 0 or 1
or 2. combination of frame x and frame y
value for each particle object will
point to a specific image in the grid
for example frame x2 frame y1 will be
here
sprite size will be the size of
individual frame in this case frames are
squares 50 x 50 pixels i want each
particle to have a different size when
drawn on canvas so we will create size
modifier and we will set it to be a
random number between 0.5 and 1. i will
set it to one number after decimal point
to reduce artifacts
so particle size will be sprite size
multiplied by size modifier to make sure
every particle is a different random
size when drawn on canvas
i want particles to fall in both
directions horizontally from the enemy
so speed x will be a random number
between -3 and plus 3. if it's minus it
will move to the left if it's plus value
it will move to the right on the
positive direction on horizontal x-axis
speed y vertical speed will be a random
number between 0 and -15 so particles
will always start moving upwards on the
negative direction on the vertical
y-axis before they start being pulled
down towards the ground by gravity
i set gravity to 0.5 let's see what kind
of curved movement we get we can adjust
it later
marked for deletion will initially be
false
i want the corks wheels and spare parts
to rotate as they fall so i will have an
angle property storing rotation angle
for each particle separately starting at
0
and the speed of that rotation will also
be randomized in this dot va property
velocity of angle rotation speed will be
random value between minus 0.1 and plus
0.1 radians per animation frame
in update method we will increase the
rotation angle by va
speed y will increase by gravity which
will give it a nice curve let's say the
particle will start moving upwards
because starting speed y is -15 as we
increase speed y by gravity from line 61
that -15 value goes closer to zero at
that point when it reaches zero it will
stop moving and it will be at its peak
height as speed y further increases by
gravity value into positive numbers it
increases by 0.5 per animation frame
that particle will start falling down
faster and faster until it disappears
below the bottom edge of canvas
this dot x minus equals speed x to move
particles horizontally
this dot y plus equals speed y to
actually apply that speed y value
affected by gravity to the vertical
coordinate of each particle
if the particle fell off screen
vertically so its y coordinate is more
than game height plus size of the
particle or if the game scrolled past
the particle so its x position is less
than zero minus particle size set its
marked variation property to
true draw method will take context as an
argument
we call draw image method
pass it the image we want to draw
and x y
width and height where to draw it on
canvas
since the particle image is a grid of
frames it's a sprite sheet we only want
to crop out one individual frame for
each particle object i will also need to
specify cropping position so source x
source y source width and source height
source x is this dot frame x from 954
times this dot sprite size from line 56
source y is frame y times sprite size
source width and source height will be
this dot sprite size like this we want
to crop out a frame 50 times 50 pixels
from the source sprite sheet
then we multiply that by size modifier
and we draw it at that scaled size
we will need an array that holds all
active particle objects i will create it
here as this.particles property on the
main game object
for each particle in that array we call
their update method like this
using es6 arrow function syntax to keep
the code cleaner
after that i call built-in filter method
on that array and i replace that
original array with a different one that
contains only particles that have marked
for deletion property set to false
all the particles with marked for
deletion properties set to true will be
removed
inside the draw method again we call for
each on each particle object we call its
draw method and we pass it context as an
argument
as it expects up here on line 73
we have our particle class ready we just
need to find a good place in our code to
add these particles i go down to update
method on game class and here where we
check for collisions between projectiles
and enemies i create a for loop
this for loop will run 10 times
and each time it runs it takes this dot
particles array and it will push new
particle object inside
i know that particle class constructor
expects a reference to the main game
object as the first argument so i pass
it this because right now in our code we
are inside that game object
each particle also needs starting x and
y coordinates so i pass it x and y of
the enemy that just collided with the
projectile
i don't want the particles to come from
the top left corner of each enemy i want
them to come from the middle so i add
enemy width times 0.5 horizontally and
enemy height times 0.5 vertically
i copy this for loop
i actually want 10 particle spare parts
to fall from the enemy when it collides
with the player and gets destroyed
down here i remove the for loop and just
push one particle
i test it
nice we have a splash of spare parts
coming out of anime when they are
destroyed by colliding with the player
player in this game is indestructible we
will make that clear by giving it a
special animated shield later in the
bonus section
i copy this code that adds just one
particle and i actually want to put it
here so that every time projectile
collides with enemy one particle follows
out
nice so now every time enemy gets hit by
a projectile one particle spare part
falls
if enemy is destroyed by colliding with
the player 10 particles come out in all
directions
i want the particles to bounce off the
floor for a specific number of times
before they fall off screen to make this
effect even more intense
i go up to our particle class and here
on line 65 i create a helper variable
i call it bounced and initially i set it
to false
i also want to define a margin from the
bottom end of canvas from which point
the particles will bounce so i call it
for example bottom bound boundary
like this and i set it to 100 pixels if
particle reaches this point i want it to
bounce so i will switch its speed y
value to its opposite
if vertical position of the particle is
more than game height minus bottom bound
boundary so somewhere around this point
and at the same time if this dot bounce
from line 65 is false
set bounced to true so that it doesn't
bounce again after this and set speed y
to its opposite value by multiplying it
times 0.5
so particles fall in it reaches this
point and its current speed is for
example plus 5. we switch it to minus
2.5 making it bounce moving upwards
again still line 70 keeps applying
gravity so eventually we reach zero and
go into positive numbers making the
particle curve towards the ground again
and eventually fall off screen it
bounces once sets bounced to true so
this if statement check will fail for
the second bounce and particle will just
fall off screen
maybe i don't want particles to all
bounce from the same vertical point on
the ground how about they bounce from a
range between this and this point
roughly to match our ground level image
so bottom bounds boundary will be a
random value between 60 and 160 pixels
from the bottom edge of canvas area
what about if we want to specify how
many times each spare part bounces from
the ground rather than having them
bounce just once
line 65 i set the initial bounced
property to zero in this check on line
74 i check if bounced is less than two
and each time we bounce i increase
bounced by 1 here on line 75.
now each particle bounces twice before
it falls off screen
down here where we create particles i
copy this for loop that creates 10
particles
we create one particle when anime
collides with the projectile i paste
that for loop here to create 10
particles when enemy is destroyed by a
projectile
so particles will come out of enemies
after three different events when enemy
collides with the player and is
destroyed we get 10 particles
when projectile collides with an enemy
we get one particle
when enemy is destroyed by projectile we
get 10 particles
so we know how to create particles when
certain events happen in our game we
know how to bounce them off floor and we
know how to control how many times they
bounce
[Music]
we also have this angle property that is
increasing by va on line 69. if you've
never done rotation on canvas this part
might be a little bit challenging but i
will try to explain each particle has a
different angle value that's increasing
by va value that's also randomized for
each particle object it means that at
any point each particle is at a
different rotation their angles have
different values
to make sure that rotation angle only
affects one specific particle and
doesn't spill out and affect other
objects we draw on canvas i will wrap
the entire drawing code between save and
restore
save method takes note of the current
canvas state when we call restore later
that restore will look for its
associated save method and it will reset
all canvas settings back to that point
in time anything done between save and
restore will just affect the code the
drawing code in between after we call
restore everything will be reset to its
original state
to rotate something on canvas we first
have to move rotation center point the
point that is normally considered
coordinates 0 0 on canvas so the top
left corner we have to translate that
point over the object we are rotating so
translate to the current x and y
position of the particle
calling translate like this moved
rotation center point from top left
corner to this dot x this dot y
coordinates of this particle
then we call built in rotate method that
takes angle value in radians i pass it
the angle property that is increasing
for every animation frame by va here on
line 69.
not sure if you can see but particles
are currently making very large circles
around their x and y coordinates it is
because we are going to another distance
of x and y from these coordinates
because of the fact that we translated
point zero zero and rotation center
point to these coordinates for all
intents and purposes this dot x and this
dot y between the save and restore in
this area of our code is considered
point zero zero on canvas and then i'm
drawing this particle at this dot x this
dot y from that translated point
further and i'm rotating it making it go
in larger circles around that center
point i fix it by changing x and y to
zero here
because position of that particle is
already defined on line 81 in translate
call
now the particles are rotating from
their top left corner so i shift them a
little bit by half of their width
and half of their height to rotate
around the center point of each particle
i have other classes about rotation for
now let's just move on if you don't
fully understand some things about
rotation don't worry it will become more
clear as you use these techniques more
often in the future we are getting a lot
of particles now if you are on a very
old computer you can reduce the amounts
of particles to get better performance i
don't have any performance issues on my
computer let me know if it runs smoothly
for you or if you had to decrease the
number of particles to get a good frame
rate
the particles don't move correctly in
relation to the ground artwork i need to
go here and include the game's scrolling
speed in the horizontal position
calculation
so this actually has to be plus
yes now it works awesome
[Music]
time for a small cleanup first of all i
want the debug mode to be disabled by
default we can still press letter d on
keyboard to toggle it on and off but
when the game first loads i want player
and enemy hitboxes and enemy lives to be
hidden by default
we have a bug in our game when the
player collides with any enemy type it
goes into a power up mode that would
make the game too easy we only want the
player to enter power up when it
collides with power up fish and later in
the bonus section there will be another
way to enter power up for skilled and
fast players who can shoot fast and big
moonfish before it comes too close
to make sure the power up works
correctly i just need to fix this
comparison operator on line 357
like this
now our sentinel sea horse only enters
power up if it collides with lucky fish
another bug is when we enter power up
player's ammo gets automatically
assigned to max ammo this is meant to
refill the ammo but if the player saved
up and has current ammo higher than
maximum ammo entering power up will
actually reduce the total amount of ammo
they have i fix it here on line 159
inside enter power up method on the
player class we only refill ammo to max
ammo if the current ammo is less than
max ammo
like this
that works
i'm using vs code editor when i press
ctrl
f i can look for all console logs i want
to delete them let's keep our code and
console clean
particle spare parts falling from the
enemies are not bouncing from the
correct area i want the bounce area
range to match the ground artwork a bit
closer here on line 66 inside particle
class constructor i set bottom bounds
boundary to a range between 60 and 140
pixels
i want to change the order in which we
draw our game elements because we are
drawing everything on a single canvas
element the order in which we call draw
methods will determine what is behind
and what's on top
i go down here inside the main draw
method on game class and i want to draw
the background first then ui elements so
score ammo timer and game over messages
then we draw player projectiles
particles and enemies on top of that you
can play with the draw order here if you
want if you want ui to be on top of
everything for example just draw it last
i think it looks better like this
because it's a bit 3d or 2 and a half d
when it's slotted between the game world
and game characters like this we can do
many other things to make the ui feel
like a part of the game world i have
lots of ideas maybe in the next class
i'll show you more game text can be
floating moving changing colors it's
easy to do it if you follow my other
coding tutorials and you understand
canvas animation well
we have a power up mode so the game
currently is very easy when we are in
power up enemies have no chance let's
add a massive enemy type that when
defeated splits into five smaller
enemies that should give the player some
challenge hope you like teeth and
tentacles
it will also introduce some tactical
decisions into the game maybe sometimes
it's better to avoid the enemy
altogether if we are low on ammo when we
know we can't deal with the little
enemies that come out of it when we
destroy the big one
i copy luckyfish class that extends the
main parent enemy class
and i rename that copy hive whale this
is a massive mechanical whale that
serves the enemy swarm as a hive vessel
containing a lot of aggressive and fast
drones width is 400 pixels and height is
227 pixels
this dot image will be looking for an id
of hive whale
i need to go to index.html to bring that
spreadsheet into the project you can
download it in the project files section
i made just one animation row for this
anime type it's a lot of work animating
all these tentacles and creating this
sprite sheet and also it's already a big
image file image with an id of hive
whale and source is assets slash hive
whale png
in style css i give that image display
none
frame y will be zero because this sprite
sheet only has one animation row
it will have 15 lives it can take a lot
of damage when defeated it will give
player 15 score points
type is hive like this and it will move
very slow so here i will override the
default speed x property from the parent
enemy class and i set it to a random
number between minus 0.2 and minus 1.4
pixels per frame
i want the enemies to be spread a bit
more down not all the way to the bottom
of the game area but maybe 95 percent of
the game height i do it by replacing
this vertical position calculation on
angular 1 angular 2 luckyfish and hive
whale with
0.95
position where enemies can spawn in the
game can be anywhere between 0 and 95
percent of game height we need this
extra space there are some large enemies
incoming
we add hive whale into the project down
here inside add enemy method on the main
game class i copy this line and i say if
randomize is between 0.6 and 0.8 add new
hive whale enemy type
and here they come i can enable debug
mode by pressing letter d to see its
massive hitbox and its current lives we
need to hit the whale with 15
projectiles to destroy it but that's not
all when destroyed 5 smaller fast and
aggressive drones come out of it and
they will go straight for our sentinel
seahorse character let's create that
enemy type
[Music]
drones are small fast and aggressive
creatures they live inside hive wells
where they collect resources and feed on
whatever the hive will swallows let's
make sure that sentinel seahorse is not
their next meal
i copy this code block and i will name
it drone
this enemy type is different they are
ambush predators and they always hide
inside the hive whale ready to jump out
and attack their prey they will not be
coming at player from the right side of
the screen like the other enemy types do
we will only see them when we destroy a
hive whale for that reason when we
create a new drone using this class we
need to pass a game object as usual but
also we need to pass it the current x
and y position it will be the current
position of the hive while we just
destroyed
i convert x and y into class properties
as we always do
image will be looking for an element
with an id of a drone
i bring it into the project here in
index html id is a drone source is
assets
drone png i created two different
animation rows each one will be moving
differently so we get some variety
frame y will be a random number either
row 0 or row 1.
each drone will have 3 lives and will
award player with 3 score points if
destroyed i will give it type drone i'm
not sure if i will use this type
property for something but might as well
declare it we might need it later
this enemy can move very fast if it
wants to it will have a random speed
range from a minus 0.5 to minus 4.7
pixels per frame
the way i want this to work is when we
destroy hive whale with projectiles it
will spawn 5 drones
in star css i give the drone image
display none
if the hive whale gets destroyed by
colliding with the player there will be
no drones because the drones would spawn
too close to the player and there will
be no time to try and aim and target
them properly it would not be a good
gameplay experience having enemies spawn
so close to the player
if projectile collides with an enemy and
if lives of that enemy are less or equal
to zero that enemy is destroyed
we check if the enemy that was just
destroyed has type property set to hive
if it is a hive whale we take enemies
array and push one new drone enemy
object inside if you remember drone
class expects game and x and y position
were to appear in the game world i want
it to appear under the destroyed hive
whale so i pass it x and y of that
destroyed enemy
let's test it i destroy a hive whale and
we have one drone coming out of it nice
let's put this code into a for loop that
runs five times to create five drones
we have five drones but they all appear
on top of each other in the top left
corner of the hive whale that's not
ideal let's spread them around a bit
starting position of the drone will be
horizontal exposition of the hive whale
that was just destroyed plus a random
number between zero and the width of the
hive whale enemy
starting vertical position of each drone
will be vertical y position of the hive
well plus a random number between zero
and height of the hive whale like this
maybe just height times 0.5
nice now the drones are more spread out
some move very fast some move slower
this is good
we get too many particles i don't want
each drone to burst into 10 particles
when destroyed what if we make the
number of particles spare parts that
fall from enemies when destroyed to be
equal to the score that enemy gives
i also make the same change here on line
383 when enemies get destroyed by
colliding with the player
now hive whale should burst into 15
particles because when defeated it gives
15 score points
each drone will turn into three spare
parts that way we won't get a massive
flood of 50 cogs and wheels when we
destroy 5 drones
[Music]
i want the game to feel good when we
score some points and destroy an enemy i
want that enemy to really pop so not
only we will turn it into spare parts
that bounce around we will also play a
dust or fire explosion from a sprite
sheet i have two special sprite sheets
for this purpose you can take them and
use them in your other projects as well
if you want many games need dust and
fire effects like this all art assets
for this episode were custom made by me
or artists i hired so there is no
copyright you can use them however you
want enjoy
we will have the parent explosion class
and we will extend it into two child
classes dust explosion and fire
explosion parent explosion class will
contain methods and properties shared
for all explosion types it will expect
game x and y as arguments because i want
the animation to play over the enemy
that was just destroyed so that x and y
position will be passed from the outside
each time we create a new explosion
object both fire and smoke explosion
will be single row sprite sheets i could
also have placed them into a single
image we will cover compact sprite sheet
animation in later class not today i
will cycle through them from left to
right from frame x0 to max frame
sprite height is the height of a single
animation frame in the sprite sheet and
it will be the same for both explosion
types
i made both sprite sheets the same
height of 200 pixels so that property
can be on the parent class it's a
property shared between all explosion
types
sprite with the width of a single
animation frame in the sprite sheet will
be different for each type because of
that it will sit on each subclass
separately we will define that in a
minute
the sprite sheets have only 8 frames so
they will animate very fast i want us to
be able to control fps frames per second
on this animation and i want that fps to
be independent of animation speed of the
rest of the game we will do that using
delta time again and we will need 2
helper variables timer that will count
from 0 adding delta time over and over
until it reaches interval value when we
reach it we will serve the next
animation frame in the sprite sheet
interval will be 1000 milliseconds 1
second divided by 15 so the animation
will run at 15 fps i can also put frames
per second in a separate property if i
want to we can control fps by adjusting
that property instead
marked for deletion will be initially
set to false as usual
we will need update method and it will
expect delta time value as an argument
we calculate delta time in the main
animation loop draw method will expect
context as an argument to specify which
canvas element we want to draw on
update method will simply animate the
sprite sheet by increasing frame x
property from line 302
draw method will draw currently active
animation frame cropped out from the
sprite sheet let's start by just giving
it image we want to draw
and x and y coordinates where to draw it
so this is the parent explosion class it
contains properties and methods shared
between all explosion types we will have
two child classes smoke explosion and
fire explosion i say class smoke
explosion extends explosion that extends
keyword creates a relationship between
these two classes and it sets up
prototype-based inheritance behind the
scenes for us smoke explosion subclass
now has access to properties and methods
that sit on explosion super class we
will also have fire explosion subclass
constructor will expect game and x and y
coordinates in index html i bring the
sprite sheets into the project here in
the props section
ids will be smoke explosion
and fire explosion
install css we give both of them display
none
i point the subclass towards that image
using getelementbyid
i'm placing this.image property on the
subclass because that image is specific
only for this subclass parent superclass
contains only properties and methods
that are shared between all subclasses
sprite width the width of a single frame
will be 200 pixels
both sprite sheets have 8 frames so max
frame will be 8.
rectangles on canvas are drawn from the
top left corner i want the explosion
animation rectangle to be coming from
the exact center of the anime rectangle
i can do it like this i'm going to give
it width and height property and i set
it to be equal to sprite with and sprite
height
i take x and y properties from the
parent class and i place them on the
child class once we have a width
property here i offset x position by
half of its width moving its center
point to the middle of the image
horizontally i will also move the
vertical y position into the middle of
the image vertically
like this
down here inside game class constructor
i create an array that will hold all
currently active explosion objects
inside update method same as we do for
particles i will call for each
and for each explosion object in
explosions array i call its update
method we will also use filter method to
remove all explosion objects that have
marked for deletion properties set to
true
inside the draw method i call for each
on each explosion object again and i
draw them passing it context notice i
draw explosions after i draw enemies so
they will be drawn on top of enemies the
order in which we call draw methods here
matters we will have two different
explosion types so same as we did with
adding different types of enemies to the
game on the main game class i define a
custom method i call add explosion we
will have a variable that will randomize
a number between 0 and 1 like this if
that random number is less than 1 for
now
take this explosions array and push new
smoke explosion inside i pass it game so
this keyword it will also need a
position so we will take it from the
anime we just collided with we will add
a reference pointing to that entire
enemy object here as an argument
x and y of this explosion will be x and
y properties from that enemy object that
is passed here let's try to add it into
the game and see what we've got so far
up here on line 419 we check if player
collided with an enemy that enemy will
be destroyed and we want to animate an
explosion at that position so i will
call this dot at explosion like this i
pass it the enemy player just collided
with and destroyed as an argument
i also want the explosion animation to
play when we destroy enemy with
projectiles so here we check if
projectile collided with an enemy if
that enemy's lives are less or equal to
zero it will be destroyed and we animate
a splash of spare parts we set marked
for deletion on that animator true and
we will add explosion here as well like
this
i test it and we are getting no
explosion animations i don't see any
console errors
let's debug it by console login
explosions array from inside add
explosions method every time we add one
we consolidate the entire array
i can see that add explosion method runs
and creates the console log for us but
the array remains empty let's see what i
did wrong probably i made a typo
somewhere
oh i see this if statement never runs
because there is no this.randomized
property easy fix we need to refer to
this temporary helper variable like this
now i'm getting a console error which is
better because this error will guide us
to where the problem is the error says
we must call constructor in derived
class before accessing this now i know
the problem is inside smoke explosion
class constructor this is a so-called
derived class when i create a new smoke
explosion object i want the parent class
constructor to run first creating
properties and values shared for all
child classes and then i want to add
this little bit of code that's specific
only for smoke explosion class to do
that i have to call the parent class
constructor
using a special super keyword i know
that parent class constructor expects
game x and y so i pass these arguments
along
it's a good lesson for me to remember on
a child class we must always call super
class constructor before using this
keyword otherwise we will get a
reference error
now when i create a new smoke explosion
we create one new blank object this
constructor will run first creating
these properties and then these
properties will be added on top of that
smoke explosion will also have access to
update and draw methods because of the
inheritance that was set up behind the
scenes by the special extents keyword we
used we fixed all the bugs and typos
when i test it i can see that everything
works and we are adding smoke explosion
into the explosions array and we are
drawing the entire sprite sheet at that
position perfect let's clean it up and
make it into a proper sprite animation
now this dust cloud is a sprite sheet we
are drawing it using built-in draw image
method on line 312. as we already did
multiple times in this class we know
that to animate a sprite sheet we need
to crop out individual frames and swap
through them one by one we do it by
passing draw image method nine arguments
image we want to draw source x source y
source width and source height to
specify area we want to crop out we want
to crop out one sprite sheet frame at a
time and destination x destination y
destination with and destination height
to tell javascript where we want to draw
that cropped out image on destination
canvas
we already have the values for
destination we just need to specify the
crop area
source x will be frame x from line 300
times sprite width from line 320. source
y will always be 0 because this sprite
sheet has only one row of frames width
of the cropped area will be sprite width
height will be sprite height
so now because frame x times sprite
width determines horizontal cropping
coordinate as we increase frame x inside
update method the frames will cycle and
animate now it works but the animation
is coming from the top left corner of
each enemy and it plays very fast also
we are not removing all the explosion
objects that already animated and we
have an ever increasing array i will
check if frame x is more than max frame
and if it is i know that entire
animation played at that point it's safe
to set marked for deletion property to
true and that explosion object will be
removed by filter method we already
defined earlier
in the browser console i can see that
the old explosion objects are being
correctly removed nice
i want the animation to run at 15 frames
per second i do it by creating a
periodic event again
timer will be counting from 0 to the
value of milliseconds defined in
interval whenever it reaches that value
it will trigger next frame in the sprite
sheet and resets back to 0 so that it
can count again
so if this dot timer from line 303 is
more than this slot interval from line
304 increase frame x by one else keep
increasing timer by delta time
accumulating milliseconds until it
reaches the interval
this will serve only the first frame is
because after timer reaches interval it
needs to be reset back to zero so that
it can count again for the next
animation frame
it still doesn't work i can see that
update method expects delta time as an
argument to be used to increase timer
value online 313. i have a feeling i'm
not passing it that value when i call it
i go down to line 422
and i pass update method on explosion
object delta time
now we are animating the explosions at
15 frames per second structuring your
code like this will allow you to set
different fps for different objects in
your game
in this case we did it because player
and enemy sprite sheets are optimized
for high frame rate but explosion
animation has only 8 frames so it looks
better if we stagger the animation speed
if you want to turn this into a mobile
game you would have to do this for all
objects player and enemies you would
have to delete some frames and stagger
their animation because current mobile
phones will struggle to surf sprite
sheets with so many frames we are using
for our characters if you want lower
frame rate spreadsheets for these
characters let me know i can easily make
them for you
the explosions are animated in the top
left corner of each enemy i want them to
be in the middle so i adjust the initial
x coordinate we pass it by half of enemy
wave
and the vertical coordinate will be
adjusted by a half of enemy height
like this
this looks good
i'm noticing that we are not showing the
first animation frame of our smoke
explosion sprite sheet it's because we
first call the update method that
increases frame x by 1 and then we draw
it i can fix it by calling draw first
and then i call update
like this
now we can see the first sprite frame as
well and it stays long enough so we can
actually notice it nice
let's delete this console log we don't
need it anymore
i can change the animation speed of dust
clouds by changing the value here in fps
property
when i set it to a very low value like 5
frames per second it becomes obvious
that they are not being correctly placed
within the game world they are static
but they should be scrolling along with
the game world for the positioning to
look right
i fix it by accounting for the current
game speed in their horizontal
coordinate calculation like this
now they scroll with the game world and
it looks as it should
i think a good fps for the sprite sheet
is around 30 frames per second
yes i'm happy with this for now
let's create a fire explosion this time
it will be very simple i copy all the
code inside the constructor into the
other child class
image will have id of fire explosion
like this i actually decided to refactor
the fire sprite sheet and now both smoke
and fire sprite sheets have frames 200
times 200 pixels in that case i can
remove sprite with on child class and i
can place it on the parent explosion
class because now it's shared for both
explosion types
in that case i can actually take all
these properties and add them on the
parent class as well
i remove them here since they will be
automatically inherited
nice that's cleaner so only the images
are specific for each class all other
properties and methods will be shared
and inherited from the parent class
down here inside add explosion method i
say if randomize is less than 0.5 create
smoke explosion else
careful about the brackets and syntax
here
else create fire explosion
nice work now sometimes we get a fire
effect sometimes we get a smoke effect
[Music]
inside game class constructor i adjust
time limit to 30 seconds
winning score will be 100 so the player
needs to get at least 100 score points
in 30 seconds to see the winning message
i set ammo interval to 350 milliseconds
so that ammo recharges a bit faster
and i set enemy interval to 2 seconds
let's test it
we have a bug i got a winning message
and there were some leftover enemies and
colliding with them reduced my score
below 100 and losing message was
displayed instead i need to make sure
that after the winning or losing message
appears colliding with enemies doesn't
affect the score
i do it here online 437 only decrease
score when we collide with an enemy if
game over is false
let's tune the game into a more playable
and challenging state
i make heath whale less likely to appear
in our game and luckyfish more likely
like this
i give hive whale 20 lives
luckyfish will have five lives
angler two will have six lives angular
one will have five lives for example
i said game with 2000 pixels this will
make the game easier as we can see
enemies coming sooner and we can plan
and manage our moves and ammo better
i try to play to get a better idea of
how much score i can get in 30 seconds
okay the game ended because we reached
winning score 100 in 25.1 seconds
let's set winning score to 80.
i can strategize now i can see there is
a lucky fish come in that will replenish
my ammo so i will use as much as my ammo
as possible before i get the refill now
i get a refill and i can go crazy with
my lasers i will be careful not to hit
the lucky fish coming at the bottom so
that i can collect it and make my power
up state longer
okay it took 24 seconds to get the score
over 80. game has a time limit of 30 000
milliseconds 30 seconds if the game runs
for that amount of time it will end we
need to get enough score points in that
time period
this is just my choice you don't have to
do this but i want the game to always
run for 30 seconds i don't want it to
end as soon as we get over the winning
score so i will comment out line 456
game will only end when time limit is
over 30 seconds
and based on how much score we managed
to get we will see a winning or losing
message
there is an element of luck in the game
we designed because it is very dependent
on which type of enemy spawns if we get
just lucky fish and hive wales we will
get a lot of score points fast if we get
only anglers it will be very hard to win
the game i gave you all the tools and
techniques you need to understand you
can now adjust the game time enemy
health and winning score yourself to
make the game as easy or as difficult as
you want it to be
the game runs well on my gaming pc but
if you have a chromebook or some very
old laptop you might be experiencing
performance issues i focused this class
mostly on handling graphics and
animation there is a whole other set of
optimizations we can do to make this run
even on the oldest machines but that's
beyond the scope of this class notable
optimizations would be for example to
draw on multiple canvas elements and
only clear parts of canvas that actually
update it
object pooling technique would also have
a massive positive effect on the
performance it means that we create a
pool of particle and projectile objects
and we just reuse them over and over
rather than creating new ones and
discarding them after one use for this
project the quick changes you can make
to improve performance would be to
increase enemy interval property to make
enemies spawn slower if your computer is
not keeping up you can also remove all
shadow properties inside ui class canvas
shadows are still not well supported and
optimized in some browsers especially in
firefox we can reduce the number of
particle spare parts that fall from
enemies when damaged and we can also
make sure they only bounce off the floor
once or that they don't bounce at all if
you are still getting performance issues
you can also merge all background layers
into one image and just animate that one
layer that will increase performance
massively same goes for our sprite
sheets i gave you sprite sheets with 37
animation frames which looks really good
and smooth in motion but if you struggle
to get 60 fps reducing the number of
frames and have each animation to be
just around 15 frames let's say and
staggering animation speed with delta
time like we did with animated
explosions would make the performance
better as well i will probably release a
version of sprite sheets with lower
frame rate for each character so you
don't have to do it manually yourself
bonus extended lesson where i add more
enemy types animated projectiles shield
and simple sound design is linked in the
video description but feel free to play
with the code and add your own features
with the techniques we learned today let
me know if you finish this project by
typing i did it in the comments if you
want more vanilla javascript game dev
come and build this game with me i will
show you how to use state design pattern
for more complex player controls and
movement and how to split our code into
individual modules click like please
i'll see you there